the puzzle was you've got two painters
and each of them can paint a house in a
particular amount of time heavens tall
efficient yeah so she paints past three
days
further on not so much some nine days
the question was what if they put paint
together
how long would it take okay now I'm
going to show you the answer shortly but
first I want you to remember the three
tips I gave you at this time is lesson
because there what's going to help us
what are the three tips there were three
verbs just tell me the book the verbs
work don't don't look see if you can
remember what's the first thing I know
the thing we need to identify is the
most important of the tips because have
a look at these questions what's the
rate what are the units there's an
obvious one yep okay days that's an
important unit this is a time unit but
then it's a rate so there's got to be
another unit right Jerri what would you
suggest house oh okay now okay so I'm
gonna run out of time if we don't get to
discretely and I'll be really sad
because I've been doing on today so I
could do it like this I could say pan I
can do one house per three days
and Fatima can do one house per nine
days but that's it a bit tricky and hunt
work me because I've got different sort
of
is happening here on the side right so
I'm going to do something I know
introduce something which I hope will
make the question a bit easier I'd love
you to write this with me okay what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take the house and
I'm going to well I'm not actually going
through you cut it up but I am going to
divide it into 9 equal sections now I
heard as we think through this question
you see why I've done divided into
sections and why I've divided it into 9
Hannah can do all 9 sections in 3 days
right so how many sections can she do
per day think careful yeah she can do in
three sections every day does that make
sense since three sections per day okay
I have a rate now okay but this rate is
better because I can compare it to
Fatima's rate
she takes nine days to do nine sections
right so therefore how many sections is
she doing each day one one section per
day now look he's the brilliant part
right before you reverse and a common
wrong answer is 12 I could see her just
add those right well you can't add these
because they're x but you can add these
because their rates right haven't
climbed together one's gonna pay three
sections yellow is gonna pay one section
so in a day Hannah and Fatima together
will do four sections per day now how
many sector so they have to do in total
yeah nine so I've got nine sections four
sections per day what operations should
I choose nine sections location four
sections per day division it's the
vision right it didn't can you see why
look carefully at the way I've written
the ending
right I'm gonna do that same thing again
I'm gonna write this as a fraction
that's four sections per day right but
the question is how long how long so
what good is supposed to be left behind
how long it's a time I want days left
behind right so you can see that's why I
can turn this into multiplication right
and then I can cancel cancel nine over
four I guess we would write that as two
and two and a quarter days right and
that's how long it takes
now just as a bit of an indent where I
asked you to pack up I suppose you could
say don't like this down you could say
two days in six hours
why have I said six hours because a day
is 24 hours right so that's a quarter
today but I would really expect you in
there actually paintings 24 hours a day
non-stop loosely feel they're probably
not doing that right what do you reckon
is a normal web tech how many how many
hours you know more that's why nicer
than 95 is perfect right now on to fine
generic company houses like it's eight
hours I'm in the killing this one uh
surprise suggest over there eight hours
eight hours is not a day it's a working
day so I think a better head for two
thousand six two thousand six hours
what's a quarter of a working day - its
Joe so I would say two working days and
two working hours because that's a
quarter a quarter of the working there
is that preservatives obviously it may
be what longer days or shorter days you
can adjust that accordingly